all good things must come to an end
mysterious villains hell-bent on Revenge
and the reappearance of multiple mortal
enemies await viewers in the final
season of Picard
what's the third and final season of
Picard all about trailers and interviews
have given us a hint about what we'll be
seeing on February 16
2023. so far we know that Jean-Luc
Picard Springs into action after
receiving a distress call from Dr
Beverly Crusher who is no longer with
Starfleet and on a humanitarian mission
to save her he'll need to get his old
Enterprise crew together this cast of
characters includes former first Officer
William Riker and counselor Deanna Troy
who both already made an appearance in
season one also making appearances are
Next Generation Mainstays Jordi laforge
and Wharf you should know that I now
prefer pacifism to combat we're all
gonna die along with seven of nine and
Rafi musicer the card sets out on a new
adventure but encounters a deadly foe
the Revenge obsessed vatic who is
dedicated to Bringing Down the
Federation and killing John Luke
needless to say the this encounter with
Beverly is going to stir up plenty of
emotions as the two haven't seen each
other in about 20 years and once
entertained the idea of a romantic
relationship Jean-Luc Picard himself
will be in an interesting place in his
life with showrunner Terry metallis
telling the all-access Star Trek podcast
that the themes from the Next Generation
finale all good things and previous
Picard seasons will continue he
described the captain in his final
season by saying he's looking back and
trying to understand how to look forward
and look for those things that are
Legacy that are family and the most
important aspects of your life that
aren't related to your job essentially
of course it won't all be emotional
reminiscing we'll get to see a lot of
fun Chemistry Between Picard and Riker
metallis continued the season kicks off
with Picard and Riker in a big way in a
kind of Butch and Sundance way and that
was something I felt was missing in the
first two seasons of Picard ready
as ever we also know that elements of
Deep Space Nine will factor into the
series such as the events surrounding
the Dominion War perhaps most
importantly Picard will see a passing of
the torch with the old generation of
Trek Heroes stepping back and the next
generation of Heroes stepping up but
that doesn't mean it's the last of
Picard and Company as metallis explained
to trekmovie.com by the end of this
you're going to say gosh I really want
to watch this Legacy character I like an
ending that promises more it definitely
could be a passing of the torch for more
in addition to the return of Jonathan
Frakes
hello beautiful Marina certis Michael
Dorne LeVar Burton and Gates McFadden
are all also returning to the fold Brent
Spiner who has played multiple
characters on the previous seasons of
Picard is back as well only this time he
won't be playing the late great Android
data instead Spiner will be playing his
evil twin lore Daniel Davis will also be
coming back as Professor James Moriarty
the self-aware Hologram accidentally
created by Jordi who became a big
problem for the Enterprise crew twice in
the show's original run and making this
whole thing a family affair LeVar
Burton's daughter Mika Burton will be
playing jordy's daughter with Ashley
sharp Chestnut playing another one of
jordy's kids and of course this third
season will also see The Return of Jerry
Ryan and Michelle Hurd as for season 3's
new big bad Amanda Plummer will be
playing the part of vatic the vengeful
captain of the shrike plumber is
probably most famous for her role as the
pistol-toting honey bunny in Pulp
Fiction or her appearance in projects
like The Hunger Games Catching Fire and
Hannibal speaking at San Diego Comic-Con
in 2022 show co-creator Alex kurtzman
explained that vatic's character will be
drawing from one of Trek's most notable
villains one of the things we love most
about Wrath of Khan is the Mind Games
between Kirk and Khan and the
one-upmanship and that has been I think
a real North Star for us this season and
the villain that we created
Star Trek Picard has seen showrunners
come and go over the course of its three
seasons with varying results season one
was helmed by show co-creator Michael
chabond the Pulitzer prize-winning
novelist whose past projects include
Spider-Man 2 and Netflix is unbelievable
shayban stepped down after season one
with show co-creator Akiva goldsman and
Terry matalis stepping in to fill the
void after season two wrapped up the
show running job fell squarely on
Metallica's shoulders with the solo
Picard showrunner boldly leading the
series towards its Grand conclusion as
you might expect metallis has quite a
bit of track experience in addition to
his work on Picard he also served as a
production assistant on Star Trek
Voyager and Enterprise with two-story
buy credits on the ladder he also has
show running experience outside the Trek
universe having overseen sci-fi's 12
Monkeys speaking to den of geek Gates
McFadden had nothing but good things to
say about metallis explaining he grew up
watching TNG and he had a certain kind
of respect for the characters who
weren't captains he really listened to
all of our ideas and we absolutely felt
encouraged to talk about everything the
same can be said about the people behind
the camera as the final season boasts an
impressive lineup of Talent two episodes
are directed by Doug arnakoski who's
helmed previous episodes of Picard along
with Star Trek Discovery and the Flash
among other shows two more episodes will
be directed by Jonathan Frakes himself
who directed episodes of almost every
modern Star Trek show as well as Star
Trek first Contact and Insurrection
bridge to Riker
can I get back to you Mr Wharf after
Frakes you can expect episodes by Dan
Liu who's worked on The Walking Dead and
Deborah campmeyer who's directed an
episode of Discovery as well as the
controversial movie hound dog
even though most of the main cast of The
Next Generation will be appearing for
Picard Patrick Stewart told den of geek
it is not a reunion Sequel and this is
one thing that I wanted to make clear I
didn't want the show to be just
sentimental what the writers and
producers have done with the card is to
create this different individual living
in a different world than the one that
we had been so familiar with in the Next
Generation but that doesn't mean there
won't be callbacks talking with Trek
core showrunner metallis said that fans
should keep an eye out for other Trek
favorites saying there is a nod to Tosh
a Yar in this season you will see Tasha
I'm I'm
supposed to be dead
unfortunately fans shouldn't expect to
see the Enterprise E the ship that
appeared in the final three next
Generation movies after the destruction
of the Enterprise D in Generations
however metallis did promise we will see
a sovereign class ship Towing Trek movie
we spend the most time on one ship this
season that is not the Enterprise that
does not mean you won't get your
Enterprise fixes that you're looking for
that ship seems to be the USS Titan and
according to metallis while seven of
nine is indeed a commander aboard the
Titan she isn't the captain
the third season will be the show's last
but it'll be going out with a bang as
metallis said in an official statement
it's most fitting that the story of
Jean-Luc Picard ends honoring the
beginning with his dearest and most
loyal friends from the USS Enterprise it
would be an understatement to say that
giving these characters a proper
send-off is an honor in May 2022 Patrick
Stewart gave his stamp of approval to
the show coming to an end explaining to
Entertainment Weekly my idea always was
that three seasons were what we really
needed to tell what was left of Jean-Luc
Picard's life and what had become of him
however a few months earlier Stewart was
painting a slightly different picture
about the show's final episode speaking
with collider in March Stewart said
followers of Picard will find that we
get to the very end of season three and
the resolution is unexpected and
questionable and I'm thrilled about that
because it leaves a question mark
hanging over Picard's head some of our
people look on this as a closure that is
coming and I don't
Jonathan Frakes said something similar
in a den of geek profile explaining as
you'll see by the end of the season it's
ripe for a continuation of some version
of what we've established in the show
not more Picard but certainly next gen
is alive and well